WILL SEE YOU LATER TOMORROW,
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR WEEKS THE MEDIA TOLD YOU IT
WAS WRONG TO WORRY ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE MYSTERIOUS LETHAL DISEASE
SPREADING RAPIDLY AROUND THE
WORLD.
IF THAT CONCERNS YOU IN ANY WAY,
DO YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO TAKE
STEPS TO PROTECT OURSELVES FROM
IT?
A NEW YORK BIGOT, CORONAVIRUS
RACIST PROFILING AGAINST ASIANS.
AN ARROGANT AT SLATE.COM.
AND A WRITER FOR
"THE SEATTLE TIMES," A PAROL
RACISM IS THE REAL ACADEMIC
FEAR.
SO ONE THE PUBLICATIONS WAG
THEIR FINGERS IN THE FACE OF
READERS AND TOLD HIM HE WAS
IRRATIONAL AND IMMORAL IN FACT
TO WORRY ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS
THAN THE ANNUAL FLU.
IDENTITY POLITICS TRUMPED PUBLIC
HEALTH AND NOT FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
AWOKEN US IS A COLT.
IT LETS YOU DIE BEFORE THE
ADMITTED DIVERSITY IS NOT HER
STRENGTH.
SO FAST-FORWARD TO TODAY.
WHAT BEGAN AS A REGIONAL
OUTBREAK IN THE CITY OF LUJAN
CHINA IS NOW SPREADING ACROSS
EUROPE.
PARTS OF ITALY SHUT DOWN TONIGHT
AND CATHOLIC SERVICES IN IN SOME
PLACES FUNERALS HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED INDEFINITELY.
TAKE A LOOK AT A GROCERY STORE
IN MILAN.
ITALY OLD -- ITALY’S ITALY’S
INDUSTRIAL CAPITAL, THE BUYING
IN BULK WITH A NATURAL DISASTER
WHICH THIS IS AND IT’S MOVING FA
CONFIRM THOUSANDS OF CASES OF
THE DISEASE SO FAR AND JAPAN
WITH INFECTIOUS AT THE SAME
LEVEL.
THE VIRUS HAS BEEN REPORTED IN
IRAN.
AT LEAST 12 PEOPLE HAVE DIED SO
FAR BUT ONE LAWMAKER SAYS THE
REAL DEATH TOLL IS AT LEAST 50.
APPARENTLY INTERNATIONAL
SANCTIONS DON’T STOP THE
CORONAVIRUS.
ON FRIDAY, THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL WARNED THAT IT’S
POSSIBLE, EVEN LIKELY THAT
AMERICA WILL HAVE A GENERAL
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK AS WELL.
THAT SHOULDN’T SURPRISE YOU.
TRAIN IS THE WORLD’S MOST
SOPHISTICATED AUTHORITARIAN
GOVERNMENT.
LEADERS HAVE SHUT DOWN ENTIRE
CITIES AND DRAG PEOPLE FROM
THEIR HOMES IN AN EFFORT TO CURB
CORONAVIRUS.
BUT IT HAS NOT WORKED.
OFFICIALS IN OUR COUNTRY
REPORTED ABOUT THREE DOZEN CASES
OF THE VIRUS IN THE U.S. SO FAR.
BUT THAT IS A MISLEADING NUMBER.
THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE NO REAL
IDEA HOW MANY AMERICANS ARE
INFECTED.
WHY?
HERE IS WHITE.
AS OF YESTERDAY, ONLY THREE
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY WERE PROPERLY EQUIPPED
TO DETECT THE VIRUS.
FEWER THAN 500 PEOPLE IN AMERICA
HAVE EVEN BEEN TESTED FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
OUT OF A POPULATION OF
327 MILLION, FOR REAL.
KEEP IN MIND FIVE AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE RIDE THE SUBWAY
EVERY DAY.
WORRIED YET?
THIS COULD BE SERIOUS.
HOW LIKELY IS AN EPIDEMIC IN THE
UNITED STATES?
ARE WE READY FOR IF IT COMES AND